um you know the the Milestones that
we're seeing we actually have on
everydayastronaut.com we have a
milestone checklist of like all the
things we're hoping to see that we kind
of need to see before the first orbital
flight of this rocket so um a big
milestone that got checked off yesterday
was a wet dress rehearsal so it's
literally like fueling the rocket up
getting ready to do everything but
lighting the engines basically so we're
talking about loading it with propellant
all the way uh this is the first time
yep right there where's the Milestones
right there at the top click that big
picture yep just anywhere that big
picture yep so the there's the what
dress rehearsal so what what's the what
dress rehearsal yep so that's where they
uh for the first time they filled it
completely to the brim with both liquid
oxygen and liquid methane now they've
done component level testing where they
fill it with liquid nitrogen which is
you know it's an inert gas so it's not
like say it leaks out it's not going to
explode uh you can just have a big giant
pool of liquid nitrogen like flooding
the area but it's not going to be an
explosion so they've done that for cryo
testing to make sure all the components
and stuff can handle you know being at
cryogenic temperatures it's kind of a
good analog before you start putting
your your fuel in your oxidizer in there
but now as of uh yesterday they fully
fueled the rocket with uh propellant
both stages the first stage and the
second stage wall fully stacked on the
on the pad like basically I mean it was
the first sense we really got of like
this is what it's going to look like
right before it takes off
you know kind of breathing coming to
life for the first time what does the
pad look like so there's a few
interesting aspects of this what's up
with the Chopsticks and the uh all of
that yeah so the the launch pad is is is
unique I've never seen anything like it
um and the prior history of of space
flight but it's a really simple launch
stand they basically have like this it
almost looks like a stool like a you
know like a milking a cow stool thing
with a whole a big giant wow I know
you're from Iowa but yeah
yes we all know what that's doing oh
yeah we all been sitting on that stool
milking cow yeah uh
with a giant hole in the middle and that
hole in the middle of that stool is
where the rocket sits and it sits on
these you know launch clamps
um and then next to it is the so that's
the orbital launch Mount and then next
to it they are the olm some people say
next to it is the orbital launch Tower
or the Olt and that is not only
um integral to fueling up the upper
stage and the upper stage has to have
propellant lines run to it so that they
can fill it with propellant and you know
all that but it also uh they ended up
making it so instead of having a big
crane on site to stack the two on top of
each other they literally just use that
Tower as a crane so the crane has these
giant arms lovingly called the
Chopsticks or the whole system can be
called mechazilla and that will grab
onto first it'll grab onto the booster
pick it up off of its off of its
transporter that transports it from the
production site lifts it up puts it down
onto the launch Mount and then it will
pick up the second stage or the upper
stage Starship and plop it down on top
of the booster and and they did that for
the first time last year actually I
think it was like Valentine's last year
was the first time they used the
Chopsticks to stack it and now they're
doing it quite frequently you know but
ultimately those Chopsticks have to
serve a second purpose they're actually
going to utilize if you say catch it's
not so much they're going to catch the
booster with these Chopsticks it's not
like it's you know a dad trying to catch
a falling child you know it's more that
the the booster and the Starship will
someday land on those arms yeah so
um they're more or less stationary I'm
sure there's some bit of you know
adjustment that the arms will do but
more or less the Rocket's going to
propulsively land and get picked up by
like what's essentially like two
like relatively small ball joints that
hold the entire thing it has to land
very precisely on these these mountains
then on onto the the launch Mount and
that's what's going to just place it
back onto the stand and allow it to be
refueled and
fly again what's the idea of using the
arms versus having uh launch pad to land
on what's what's the benefit you are
basically removing the mass of what
would be heavy Landing legs and you're
putting kind of that Landing
infrastructure onto a ground system so
you're not having to carry those Landing
legs into orbit but it's also elevated
off the ground is there some aspect to
that where you don't have to balance the
thrust and all the
you
you can negate some of those like
there's like plume plume interactions
there's like you know the exhaust
hitting concrete and especially with the
rocket this big it's gonna you know use
like three Raptor engines firing if you
know if you have them firing really
close to the ground you're just gonna
absolutely destroy and crater the ground
and you're gonna have to refurbish the
the ground and the landing pad every
time and you know or have huge Landing
legs that are super long and and tall
you know to make it so it's it's
elevated enough to not do that
um so yeah you're kind of you're
avoiding that whole mess by by catching
it high enough off the ground that you
don't have to factor that in and it's
that's how many engines are involved in
the landing as far as the three Raptor
engines well we haven't actually you
know we haven't today seen the exact
Landing sequence so it might be
something like at first they might light
up you know seven or something or nine
or something some number to to
accelerate quickly or decelerate quickly
without the same thing
um and and then shut it down to three or
something for a little bit more granular
control because unlike Falcon 9 Starship
has enough engines and variability to
actually if it needed to hover you know
to maybe more precisely align itself
with the pad it would have that
capability
um and especially having multiple
engines you know if you only have a
single engine running you can't really
roll You Know Your Role axis you can do
pitch and yaw because the the engine is
kind of like a Rudder it it can move in
two axes so you can easily pitch and yaw
the vehicle but to actually use Roll
Along its vertical axis you you would
either need like auxiliary engines to
roll it or you'd need a pair of engines
so they can be opposed and induce rolls
so by having two or three running they
have all three axes of control that they
would need kind of like a broomstick you
know and
uh bouncing a broomstick on your hand
they can just move it over and if they
need to align it to those Landing Nubs
you know on the landing arms and stuff
like that then uh they can do that